place de première année école
Saint-Pierre clavaire Montréal
mathématique les élèves ont une
enseignante dédiée et il compte aussi
sur Nassera pour répondre à leurs
nombreuses questions
[Musique]
une centaine d'écoles dans celle-ci
participe au projet pilote le principe
est le suivant des éducatrices en
service de garde comme Nacéra viennent
prêter main forte dans la classe d’une
ou d'un enseignant tu fais ton dessin et
la phrase mathématique et l'aide les
élèves à s'organiser à comprendre les
consignes et les ratures aux besoins je
considère que ça changeait ma vie cette
année là bravo Isabelle enseigne depuis
31 ans elle constate des impacts directs
sur ces élèves le fait que j'ai une
asséra a fait en sorte que mes élèves
ont appris à lire plus rapidement
d'habitude je suis au mois de décembre
fin décembre cette année 1er novembre
Nassera elle gagne des heures de travail
et elle est désormais complice des
progrès des enfants ses élèves là c'est
plutôt pour eux que ça fait beaucoup de
choses
nous ça nous ça nous apporte une
nouvelle expérience je ne suis pas juste
éducatrice je suis aussi aide de classe
selon un rapport préliminaire préparé
pour le ministère de l'Éducation plus de
80% des enseignants et plus de 90% des
aides à la classe il voit des effets
bénéfiques pour eux et pour leurs élèves
ce projet implanté sous l'ancien
ministre de l'Éducation Jean-François
Roberge était intitulé au départ aide
enseignant comme en Ontario mais il est
devenu aide à la classe un concept
québécois le syndicat ayant proposé
l'idée est agréablement surpris de la
réussite du projet pour le personnel de
soutien est-ce que les gens nous disent
entre autres c'est la valorisation qui
amène l'aide à la classe aussi de
pouvoir faire partie inclusivement de la
solution en éducation un sentiment
partagé par l'un des plus importants
syndicats en enseignement pour plusieurs
enseignants ça a été la bouffée d'air
qu'il n'attendait plus jusqu'à quel
point j'ai le droit de répondre à un
élève d'aller chercher où dans le texte
mais les syndicats préviennent
unanimement que les éducatrices en
service de garde ne doivent pas devenir
des techniciennes en éducation
spécialisée moins bien payé et l'aide à
la classe ne règle pas le problème de
fond souligne la FAE qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé dans la classe pour que les profs
ne soient plus capables de gérer ça tout
seul et ça le projet pil ne répond pas à
cette question-là avec 10 millions et
demi de dollars le projet a été déployé
dans 850 classes soit plus de 15000
élèves mais à quand un déploiement dans
toutes les écoles du Québec et bien ça
dépend des négociations qui sont
toujours en cours entre le gouvernement
et le milieu de l'éducation mais
jusqu'ici chose certaine le projet
obtient de bonnes notes moi j'ai vu avec
un disque sur 10 sur 10 combien je peux
tu dire 11
on peut plus reculer là c'est bénéfique
pour les enfants je disais tous les
enfants
gagnent avec ce projet là on a besoin de
ce coup de pouce supplémentaire là donc
on peut plus revenir il y a un avant
puis après à ce projet-là un avant et un
après aussi pour les élèves qui veulent
désormais garder leur Nacéra en fait
c'est qu'elle est vraiment gentille elle
nous aide au fond au cahier français
elle nous aide à faire des mathématiques
ici Julie Marceau Radio-Canada Montréal